no se sabe el dictador que la patria se
lleva en el corazón y en los actos y no
se priva por decreto escribió Gabriel
borich en su cuenta de Twitter se
transforma de esta manera en el único
líder de un gobierno progresista de
América Latina en condenar de una manera
tan contundente el accionar de Ortega
que análisis hace usted esta postura que
toma Boris
postura que tal Santiago saludarte la
verdad es que más que una postura lo que
hace Boris es el coherente con su
convicción de personales convicciones
personales que ha sido constante desde
que era candidato presidencial luego
como presidente ya asumido en chile para
poder establecer de que su preocupación
y foco los Derechos Humanos
respeto estaba marcando no solamente lo
que ofrecía en su programa a la
población chilena sino que también en la
política exterior eso lo lleva por
ejemplo a plantear de que Venezuela eso
dio la cédula de Derechos Humanos lo
propio también en Nicaragua por supuesto
también en Cuba y en esa perspectiva el
presidente boric quizás una de las
líneas más coherentes que tiene
justamente su defensa estos derechos
humanos y de ahí que no llame la
atención en Chile de que haya denominado
dictador a pesar de que sí llama la
atención en todo el grupo de izquierda
progresista en chile y en América Latina
pero es coherente con lo que ha sido su
su presentación respecto a estos temas
políticos y particularmente vinculado a
derechos humanos mencionaba recién a la
izquierda y al progresismo en América
Latina no cómo interpretan en general la
postura precisamente de este tipo de
gobiernos de la región
la postura de la región está muy marcada
por visión ideológica y expectativas
ideologías que se han ofrecido a la
población tanto en el caso Alberto
Fernández Argentina Lula en Brasil el
mismo Vero Castillo en el Perú y hoy día
boluarte que no olvidemos que también
Desde esa misma línea al propio tema de
de Petro o López Obrador en México ha
preferido muchas veces y teniendo una
visión mucho más ideológica y más
concreta Más allá de las convicciones o
el discurso que ellos tienen respecto a
derechos humanos lo que hoy día ha hecho
boriche colocar un punto de inflexión y
progresivo de América Latina en términos
de coherencia y política particularmente
y que deberá llevar probablemente a un
debate y si es que no a un cambio de
posición y así lo esperamos en términos
de Cuál ha sido la posición de otros
gobiernos donde han dejado a Gabriel
Boris solo en esta defensa de Derechos
Humanos respecto a las medidas que ha
tomado Ortega en Nicaragua hablemos un
poco de los vínculos entre estas dos
naciones que lazos han unido
históricamente a chile y a Nicaragua
Cómo han sido estos vínculos
y son vínculos que pasan por diversas
materias hay vínculos ideológicos
obviamente hacia la lucha Revolucionaria
el año setenta una de un intercambio
importante de perspectiva visiones e
incluso recursos humanos más llamémosle
combatientes de aquella época o aquellos
que estaban por la idea Revolución que
se derivaba de lo que había sucedido en
Cuba pero también hay una larga historia
Como sucede con otros países
Centroamérica y en relaciones estatales
tanto a nivel de gobierno a educación a
nivel de salud a nivel también económico
financiero y también Ah Es lo que se
respira relaciones militares donde hay
una larga y hemos intercambio entramos
países